hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i'm
here to make a big update guys as usual
on amc ngme i also want to go with you
through what is happening on the global
market we're going to discuss the good
plays as well from yesterday and i'm
going to show you exclusively even for
those who are not in discord some of the
plays that i posted today let's get into
it alright guys yesterday we started
with dme today we're going to start with
amc so uh the close has not happened yet
guys it's 8 p.m here in france so i need
to go dinner soon um
i'm gonna update you guys if something
crazy happens before the close but i'm
gonna make my video right now amc
starting at 18. we are right now up
three percent uh we didn't start the day
very good we started uh flash then we
went a little bit lower we found some
support
let's see we thought where we found
support i have not prepared this video
so i'm gonna analyze live with you of
course i follow the press action
um
but
i
i noticed that we didn't reach the 16.3
level which is rather good news when a
support is not reached and we have a
bullish reaction before it is usually um
you know signaling that bulls are just
ahead of the support which is once again
rather good news but it's too early to
celebrate uh for now the good thing that
i'm seeing guys which is positive
is that we have
we know you know we had like eight can
eight eight
red candles then one green one red and
now one green again so this is the
beginning of a consolidation so
for now it is truly to say that we have
buttons um
we are coming close to some strong
supports you know because once again the
breakout level
is always a strong support why so the
breakout once again i remind you guys
this is what i was explaining in
yesterday's video we are looking for
this kind of signal guys and once again
on amc as you know there are many many
tricks but whenever the signals are very
clean they are usually working well here
the whole way down guys we had a lot of
fake signals and here we had a good uh
and clear signal which was a breakout
with volume increase so this was the
beginning of
um this massive move up that happened
here and whenever we have this kind of
uh levels that occur with increasing
volume and that you know uh leave a mark
that is uh strong both on the bare side
and on the ball side uh this levels are
usually acting very well as support in
this case when we have an upside
breakout or resistance it works the same
way for downside breakouts so here
i was simply not expecting we go that
low uh we're here
we have not reached this level yet at
16.3 i don't know if we're gonna reach
it maybe uh what i know is that if we
come here all the bulls that didn't jump
in the trade here they would think like
all right this is my chance you know so
this is the kind of reasoning that
happens when we get back close to this
levels of course
we need to come back close to this
levels before
um it is too late and investors
forget what happened here and here this
memory is still a fresh memory i
personally remember that day very well
yes i was in panama i think it was my
first live training day um
i was very excited and i hope i'm gonna
have this excitement very soon again so
i can sum up quickly what i was saying
in my yesterday's video i said that
because of the fact that we went that
low guys in the second wave this is not
looking like a good second wave maybe
we're gonna have a deeper second wave
and a massive third wave uh i really do
hope so but
what i
must say is that whenever we go beyond
the 61.8 percent retracement which was
here at 21 the probability of a massive
third wave that happens you know in one
way is just lower so right now once
again my preferred scenario
uh is that at some point we're gonna
bounce so once again i don't know if we
have reached the low or not i think that
you know maybe we're gonna reach the low
tomorrow maybe not but at some point
we're gonna have here
a massive rebound okay
so massive maybe to the 22 or 26 area
here and then here we're gonna have
bears attacking right so rejection then
coming back and hopefully we're gonna
consolidate here we need this
consolidation once again to build up
energy and to prepare guys for what we
are waiting for for so long
what i personally um
think will happen this year uh
hopefully before may june this was the
target i had uh you know in you know at
the beginning of the year i was saying
may i was saying apple made and i was
saying may june then in uh in end of
march we had this huge run-up so i was
saying all right maybe it's gonna happen
a little bit before you know it's hard
to predict but um i think we are still
in the same area uh why is it gonna
happen i think before
june or maybe july i don't know let's be
very honest here uh just because we have
this download sloping trendline that is
very clearly identified as the major
resistance where we have all the bears
located so if we manage to go through
that
bears would have nowhere to hide all
right so
shorts would start to cover we're gonna
have some crazy things for sure i'm not
sure we're gonna be able to have this
breakout i really do hope so i
personally believe a lot in it uh but
when i'm very very convinced about is
that if we do
guys this is gonna be absolutely massive
this is gonna be the um i think the
biggest
the biggest quiz that we have ever seen
on the market i really do hope so i
think we have all the ingredients that
are reunited to uh for the scenario to
happen but for now guys we're not here
yet so uh let's talk about what we're
having right now which is still not
amazing but we're having this
consolidation that i told you guys
yesterday we are waiting for i will show
you that you know we have here this
consolidation so in this situation we're
looking at a for a consideration here of
this whole move down or of this only
move down a consideration here okay so
we can see things in different time
frames on the lower time frame we want a
small consideration here then rebound on
a higher time frame we want a big
consideration here
or go right away through it but once
again everything that goes too quickly
without consolidating without taking
back energy i was guys uh i remember
during my life telling you
i hope we're gonna make a pose at some
time at some point because if we don't
then you know bears are just gonna take
their revenge and
here for me it was good enough but you
see in the end we didn't pose enough
this market was just going too high too
quickly and whenever this happens bears
are attracted to everything that goes
too high too quickly and they just
jumped at this
opportunity and and they push back the
price action close to the breakout area
where everything has started so to sum
up my view guys i think that
we are out of trouble soon maybe not
right now um i think that we're gonna
need
we're gonna have a strong move up
happening soon but i don't think it's
gonna be really the third
wave maybe it's just gonna be you know
the first wave of the third wave and
we're gonna have a longer uh third wave
i'm not sure what i just think is that
right now we're gonna have a rejection
occurring at 22 or 26 and then here
there's going to be one more opportunity
in maybe mid-may um to jump in the
straight so i think that
you know buying now is good uh buying
here is not good and waiting here is
good as well so let's go we're gonna see
for now today is not a bad day and um
and i think that we are close close to
the end of this hopefully second wave uh
jimmy guys uh what is happening here
same thing guys look at that this is
even nicer okay jamie's behaving much
better than amc you know
i mean
all right bam let me get back you see
guys i was using the logarithmic scale i
need to switch i'm back to the log scale
right now to the regular scale i'm not
using the same scales on both stacks
uh for the for the reason that
uh i have better reactions when i use
the regular scale on gme so you always
need to switch from one to the other and
check where you have the best reactions
what is a good reaction is whenever you
have a consolidation that is giving you
pure
like clean reactions all right this is
telling you that this streamline is
followed by uh traders by a lot of
traders so this is what you want to be
doing as well all right trend lines are
like a guide
for traders all right so uh here this
one land is clearly as you can see uh
acting a little bit like a magnet here i
was telling you yesterday guys that we
are having 141.8
as a support and today
okay we went to 142.
fair enough um the market lacks round
numbers too so fair enough uh 141.842
it's very close we found support at our
support level and got a bullish reaction
so
uh
i mean it's looking just like on amc
guys uh i'm back on the first time frame
right now we are considerating here so
we need we like those these
considerations um
i mean we like it when we are at the top
of the consolidation because a
consideration if you are at the bottom
and you move down it is looking like
something that is gonna drop here but
whatever we consolidate and we are at
the top of the constellation uh it's
looking good because it's showing that
bears are not in control anymore so um
as long as we're in this kind of neutral
area between 142
and
153 i would say once again guys i just
you saw i just took this number
like i took the highs of this
consolidation and i found 153 for those
who are watching my videos often you
remember what is 140 53 it's our fib
ratio guys so it's once again very
interesting to see that's whatever
method you use whatever technique
whatever time frame whatever move you
measure you very often gonna find these
levels because the market is organized
around this
levels because
many different traders are using many
different techniques that converge to
this levels that then act as support
resistances magnet uh whatever you want
and there are the levels to watch for
breakouts to know where the market will
take a direction so here
um i don't have much to say yes let's be
honest it's a good day but we need to
see more we need to see the price action
you know coming back above this 153
level this would be a good sign we are
still looking good on jme guys
uh nothing new this vibration we are
still
far above the 50 uh fib ratio um we have
the rsi that's
daily time frame that is
starting to go up
so we have
an inflection of the rsi which is good
guys so this is not a strong
inflection i agree
uh but it's still good to see
this curve starting to go higher even
before touching the 50 level on amc it
is still dropping a little bit
so um yeah gm is doing much better than
amc and
and this is giving me a lot of hope guys
because when i see jme
i'm bullish i'm bullish this is
looking very good guy guys for a third
wave to come um we're gonna need as well
to have uh the global market with us and
this is the good thing guys let's
quickly have a look at what happened
here
uh today i personally made money on
pretty much everything i bought
yesterday i told you guys i think in the
video i did before i bought that
233 um
and this was the day before i'm not sure
but i have this long position here i
didn't buy here i took profits of the
short position i built here guys once
again i shared everything with you in
this code and uh then i took a long
position here at 338 i shared this
thread id as usual guys
triple cube
okay a good way to play it is to buy
339 and stop loss 335 all right this is
what i told you guys yesterday uh what i
did is that i bought a slightly lower
sometimes i modify um the levels i'm
giving you because i'm live and i see i
need to modify quickly but it's pretty
much the same thing i did um and of
course for the platinum members i gave
you the exact level because this is for
the gold area but whatever
and right now i'm gonna personally take
uh profits very
early guys and re start to rebuild my uh
short position because to me this market
is still moving sideways it's gonna be
ups and downs so buying and downside
selling on the upside is the right way
to trade this market so this is what i'm
gonna keep doing this is uh this helped
me to make a lot of money guys in the
past three months i started to be short
here as you can see when the breakout
occurred i of course gave you guys this
in discord a lot of you i know made
money with me in the move down and and
right now we are just you know playing
uh buying buying low selling high it's a
quite easy market i would say quite uh
predictable so uh hopefully because uh
some other markets like amc or gme i'm
not that easy to predict i'm a sam but
hopefully
we still have those uh you know basics
that we can count on to make money uh we
then had oil guys oil is showing very
good signs so here
i'm still long i have call options guys
i have uh
i bought some shares here at 93 i was on
uso but it's pretty much the same i took
a little bit of profit roughly half of
my position right now here because we
arrived on this triangle look at that
guys i don't know if you are if you are
positioned on some energy stocks but
guys it's gonna start to be hot again i
personally have long positions on many
energy stocks i gave you a lot of them
guys i gave you dte i gave you uh dt by
the way this morning i told you guys
it's time to take profit this is another
uh trade idea that i gave you guys back
in the time when when we had the first
breakouts and here uh so there are a lot
of those stocks um
if you're not with me in this code i'm
not gonna give you all of them here uh
but i can tell you that all the stocks
guys are gonna start to
move strongly higher if we have this
breakout confirmed so we're gonna see
we're gonna analyze that um i'm
personally happy with the position i
have maybe i'm gonna increase some of
them uh but this is looking like a
breakout here so we're gonna see if we
are able to have this increase in volume
once again guys for those who want to
understand everything about breakouts
just follow my course guys i did it for
you um and now we have
multiple payments that is available for
those who cannot afford a one-time
payment um they're gonna be maybe later
in a few months some discounts as well
like i did at the beginning but uh for
now i made a multiple payment uh option
for those who are interested to get the
course and once again guys i can tell
you that this course will help you to
identify all of the situations and that
this is what i'm using guys in this code
for a pretty long time and
uh i'm very sure that a lot of you are
happy about uh what we are doing here
and we're going to keep using those
techniques guys because this is how you
make money in the long run and here i
can tell you that this is a very nice
breakout situation we only missed the
volume breakout and those who follow the
course are now uh
understand fully why uh if we have this
breakout with increasing volume this is
going to be a victory of bulls that is
probably going to be followed by a
strong move up we're going to discuss
target later but i can tell you guys
it's going to be maybe around 140 i
don't think in june but before the end
of the year i'm very sure we're going to
see this area between 115 and 145
i think we're gonna revisit the high 145
and maybe even break out above that
level if this happens guys
i don't know how the market would be
looking because for inflation it would
be really really bad we are not there
yet uh silver as well guys uh keep
pushing higher so once again this is the
trade i gave you we bought here guys you
bought with me i hope
uh and another one guys utter so i gave
you utter as well guys so of course
sometimes i'm giving you trades that are
not working you know but here i'm
showing you what uh worked well
um because i think it's interesting
to see uh how those uh
you know trades were built so here at
was identified on the fifth of april
guys
and i was saying to buy between three
and three eighty stop loss at two target
five six all right so we both here at
373
roughly and this morning i told you guys
how to move your stop loss once again
this is in the course for those who are
interested
uh whenever you're in a winning trade
sometimes you need to take profit
sometimes you need to let it run here uh
the strategy i gave you guys this
morning is to take 50 of the profit uh
at 5.5 just below this
resistance at 5.7 and to let the rest
run tomorrow i'm going to show you where
to adjust the stop loss but for the once
again those who follow the course you
know already where to put your stop loss
tomorrow
and right now here it's quite nice what
is happening because we are breaking out
above 575 so what does it mean for now i
mean it means that bulls are very strong
uh
was this resistor of resistance a very
strong one one two three four
ten reactions uh look the rsi starts to
be overbought so an rsi can stay
overboard for quite some time uh but
whenever it is overbought it's gonna
attract some bears so i think that here
we might push higher the uh
next resistance is here tomorrow i'm
gonna give you some levels guys i think
it's time to take full profit here
uh because if we have a breakout coming
from the lows as for amc as for
everything guys that is not
consolidating even if we break out we're
gonna re-test so here
taking the rest of the profit at 7.5
make total sense for tomorrow for those
who are still in this trade moving the
stop-loss higher
and let it run make sense as well i
would uh personally take profit here
uh and then we can if we have a breakout
here guys without consideration i would
personally not get in this trade i don't
like to trade breakouts that happened
after there was no consideration uh
because they are just you know
not very safe not very reliable so let's
see what's going to happen uh but maybe
we're going to have something like that
and a crazy move up we're going to
analyze all of that and i gave you
exclusively guys one trend that i gave
you this morning tk80 that had a nice
run up here i told you
um
i'm not sure if i said that to the
platinum guys or where
i mentioned that
okay whatever i don't see it uh oh yeah
it was here
okay
okay we were already there whatever i
didn't give you any alert because it was
too late actually
so this was when i saw uh the the huge
breakout when i was in panama we were
already we had already touched 475 which
was the resi which was the resistance
and now we are putting back so now i
gave you the alert this morning
i personally didn't jump in this trend i
don't trade all the alerts i'm sending
you guys because i'm happy with the
position i'm having right now um
but it's a good alert because we are
coming back on the 20 day moving average
we have to break out with concentration
and volume and we are at a fib ratio
uh so to me this is a strong support and
this is what i posted uh in my discord
once again i'm giving you guys this
trend that is still valid i posted it
this morning a little bit lower let's be
honest but the level is still attractive
to me uh let's see i think that tk8 can
have a nice run up
of course guys we use a stop loss um
and we have oil breaking out
that's pretty interesting so let's
conclude guys amc is still at 18 um you
know so i'm pretty much neutral between
18 and uh 19 if we're able to close
above 19 it would probably be the
beginning of this uh new move up i think
we're gonna have a strong move up
happening soon but i don't think it can
really go to the 1700 area right away
we're gonna need to make a pose
um jimmy is looking great guys i really
like this chart um
i bought some amc this morning so it was
the same
uh
i need to finish my to buy my
collapsions on amc
just because i said i i would do it so i
finish it and then i'm gonna start to
buy more gme i'm just waiting for the
spread to um to tighten a bit
amc still training at a discount
compared to gme but maybe there is a
reason for that if the spread is lasting
you know a long time and we have some
nice volume that is exchanged with the
spread then maybe this um
you know the the ratios they gave you
which was around six will need to be
revised and we're gonna analyze all of
that but the longer we stay with uh this
new levels jamie at 150 amc at 18
roughly the longer it makes me think
that i need to buy some gme so let's see
we're gonna see what happens guys i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so that you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore see
you guys